اهلا بكم من جديد من الانتصارات المفاجئه
الى الدموع والاهداف الرائعه وصله الستار
على نسخه كاس العالم قطر 2022 بعد اربعه
اسابيع من التباري والتنافس بين المنتخبات
العالميه دوله مشاهدينا نعود معكم الى
ابرز اللحظات التي ميزت هذا المونديال كاس
العالم 2022 والتي ستبقى عالقه في ذاكرتي
جميع محبي كره القدم
البدايه من المغرب ستبقى دوره هذه السنه
مثل ما ذكرنا مرتبطه بانجاز المنتخب
المغربي بعد اصبح اسود الاطلس اول فريق
افريقي وعربيه يصلوا الى المربع الذهبي
للبطوله بعد مسار الاستثنائيا اثاره اعجاب
متتبعي الكره وفاز المغرب باول المباراه
له في المونديال منذ عام
19980 والثالثه على الاطلاق بتامين فوز
مثير اثناء السفر على بلجيكا قبل ان
يتجاوز كندا ثم يقصي اسبانيا والبرتغال من
دوري الثمن والربع
وفي اكثر النتائج غير المتوقعه شهد
مونديال قطر فوزا تاريخيا للمنتخب السعودي
على نظيره الارجنتيني المتوجي بالمونديال
مرتين والذي حل بالمركز الثاني او اللي
فاز هذا منذ قليل بقياده الاسطوره ليونيل
ميسي يتوقع الكثيرون ان تكتسح الارجنتين
السعوديه غير ان لاعبي المدرب ارفي رونار
حققوا المفاجاه الكبرى وانتصروا في
مباراتهم الاولى
فيفا
وفي نتيجه اخرى غير متوقعه تعرضت المانيا
بطله العالم 2014 لهزيمه مفاجاه امام
اليابان في المباراه الافتتاحيه للفريقين
قبل ان تتعادل مع اسبانيا وتفوز على
كوستاريكا بصعوبه ولم يساعد الفوز الاخير
رفاقه على تجاوز دار المجموعات لتكون هذه
المره الاولى ثمانين عاما التي يفشل فيها
المنتخب الالماني في التقدم الى مراحل
خروج المغلوب من البطوله وقالت بعد الخروج
من دوري المجموعات ان يحصل الامر بهذه
الطريقه يبدو وكانه في المرعب
دخلت استيفاني برابر التاريخ في هذه
البطوله ايضا كاول امراه تحكم او تحكم في
مباراه في كاس العالم للرجال وجنبا الى
جنب مع مساعدتها نويزا بعد من البرازيل
وكريم دياز من المكسيك شكلت الفرنسيه جزءا
من ثلاثي تحكيم نساء بالكامل لاداره
مباراه كوستاريكا ضد المانيا في مباراتهما
الاخيره بالمجموعه الخامسه ياتي ظهور
فريبارا الاول في كاس العالم بعد ان اصبحت
في عام 2019 اول حكم تتولى مسؤوليه اداره
مباراه في دوري الدرجه الاولى الفرنسيه
واول من اداره في دوري ابطال اوروبا والى
الاسطوره الارجنتينيه لونا المستي حتى قبل
المباراه كتب البالغ من العمر 35 عاما
التاريخ في هذه البطوله حيث سجل في
المباراه رقم 1,000 في مسيرته وساهم في
جميع المباريات التي فاز فيها منتخب بلادي
في هذا المونديال الذي اعلن قبل ايام ان
كاس العالم 2022 سيكون اخر ظهور دولي له
ومن الاسطوره الارجنتينيه الى الاسطوره
البرتغاليه كريستيانو رونالدو من المحتمل
ان تكون هذه اخر كاس عالم يشارك فيها
كريستيانو رونالدو وبدلا من النهايه
المجيده التي كان يتمناها غادر المهاجم
البالغ من العمر 37 عاما المونديال باكيا
بعد ان هزم فريقه او هزم على يد المغرب في
ربع النهائي وشهد رونالدو غير قادر على
اخفائي مشاعره وهو يغادر الملعب في السادس
ثم ماما الى غرفه تبديل ملابس المنتخب
البرتغالي بعد ان توالت خيبات الامل التي
عاشها في مونديال قطر حيث لم يدخل رسميا
في مبارتين متتاليهتين مفاجاه اخرى غير
متوقع
هذا الكاس كاس العالم 2022 حيث جاء راقص
سامبا الى مونديال قطر باعتباره ما
المرشحين الاوفر حظا لخطف الكاس الذهبيه
غير ان الفريق
ظهر في جل المباريات باداء متوسط لم
يؤهلهم لتجاوز دور الربع ضد المنتخب
الكرواتي ولم يقدم المنتخب البرازيلي في
المونديال اداء يشفع له بالتتويج بالكاس
باستثناء امطار شباك كوريا الجنوبيه
بالاهداف ورقصات الاحتفال طبعا هذه
الرقصات المجنونه التي ستظل عالقه في
اذهان محبين نجوم السامبا رغم انه مذيع
القطر لن يكون ذكرى جيده بالنسبه للبرازيل
[موسيقى]